Oh rather than that and across the sea
center for adventure and brush to see if
young man Laura travel day and conquer
bake Canada if I were driving through
the rural pots condo we found a really
cool old church let's reach it
presenting Laura darling on
we've now arrived in Megan and it's so
cute it's so different to all the big
cities that we live in just super quiet
hey
so we're staying at the high hostel in
Maynooth and it's really quite sweet and
for what it is the rooms and massive
compared to what we've been staying in
look at this and we've got some awesome
green walls as well whoa isn't that
right Laura are you happy good now we're
going to explore the forestry of
algonquin park which I thought might be
like a place where loads of people would
be and maybe some cabin houses here but
apparently now it's just one big kind of
wilderness that's huge and you just
explore it let's go find some animals we
have to be quiet I guess we might see
some moose or a bear isn't that right
Laura yes baby fair enough
didn't hear that yes the trees oh the
wild Laura
right where's the moon oh there's did it
that I think that's book I don't know it
was me it was me second day it's ready
to make a wish yes but everyone that
stays at the hostel you get a free tour
around the jail to death row and places
like that so that's what women do